hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today
we're in wrap up mode so let's wrap
up these ants in an ant pie of some kind
and get into episode 136
episode 136 is really a mop up
of all the unknown unclean pieces of
information we thought we needed or
thought we had but didn't we saw
characters we haven't seen in a long
time and i
sort of enjoyed that especially given
tagashi didn't hide from the trauma and
difficulties that essentially come from
war
the dead were laid to rest the
horrificness of life is that it proceeds
whether people are dead or alive whether
we miss them or not and
all we can do is hang on and hope things
get better or easier or clearer or i
don't know something sorry this is
really dark
i mean but but so was the ark so maybe
maybe this is fine i'm okay with this
and seeing all these characters in
different stages of that process
was very cathartic for a me
just me maybe you but mostly me it was
crying season in fact
definitely as soon as i realized who
little ant buddy was because she's been
on such a journey from start to finish
that i had given up hope we would find
out more about her
and find out where she'd gone and i
really didn't think that she was
the ki i don't know i probably did
anyway she's been on such a journey
and i feel for her i felt for her i felt
so much for her takashi has such a habit
of leaving things unsaid or unfinished
and that's just a note that we have no
idea what's happened to piggy or cow guy
i don't know what's his name
um kilwa's brother like piggy i don't
know that's the name i remember so
that's the name he has
we only seem to get closure on very
specific situations and so i find it
interesting
which ones we do get that closure for
tugging on my heartstrings like that
with her and her mother who knew her
immediately because she's a
mum stop it's too much
i'm far too susceptible to that kind of
emotional manipulation
and apparently so was shrimp bug guy
which is unfortunate for him
octo buddy managed to achieve so much in
the short time he had to influence
people and he really is quite the mvp of
the series
when we think about it given the lessons
he's taught kiwa
also cause let's note that killa is
ready to set a boundary
he's sick of just taking what god is
willing to hand him and thanks to
octobuddy he now has expectations for
friendship this kid
whose only friend was one of his butlers
who he certainly didn't respect now he's
got a friend he does respect and who's
shown it to him and he's not the same
character anymore
not the same person meanwhile gone a 12
year old boy
is all kinds of messed up because he
isn't a 12 year old boy anymore like is
he a
30 year old boy or did he just like
shrink that's weird
physically emotionally i mean what are
we even supposed to i'm amazed he's
alive
has someone cut his hair can you cut
hair that goes on into infinity
should you try did he like shrink back
when his hair got cut like what's the
deal with that and i really don't
understand how keel was going to
dark side gone back to life is he gonna
just zap him until he's back
you know i could imagine that in a sort
of pikachu reviving ash kind of way or
at least the attempt the soundtrack for
this scene
between kiwa and i guess the glass wall
to gone was wonderful and it spoke very
clearly to the romance rather than
purely platonic friendship
at least on kilwa's part it's very much
the soldier returned from war vibe
which is for me thematically yummy is
kiwa going to hunt down
someone else who can heal if pito could
do it then others must be able to
maybe kill one knows who they are and
will just hunt them down eat them
take their energy and come back and fix
it himself he seems the type i like the
idea that revenge is kind of the reason
kilwa wants khan to survive
it's such an enemies-to-lover's kind of
trope except backwards sort of qr saying
that gone always leaves him to clean up
but now he'll clean up and
gon will apologize all of that is quite
the entertainment factor
meanwhile welfin has survived and he's
an old man dog now
moving on with his life his dogginess is
in the company of still
the ultimate villain of the series and i
cannot begin to tell you
how much this is ah
like we had a whole arc a whole arc
where we were questioning humanity
versus bug
and then there's this guy this guy just
survives you know like i just
and that's truly the thing the ants are
just on a hunt to find the person they
trusted and remember feeling loyalty
toward
in a way their purity is sort of
maintained you know in
in in that way and they're hopping a
ride with bees off because they need to
hop a ride with bees off they don't have
anyone else to hop a ride with and
they're not beholden to the behaviors of
humans on a wrap-up episode
that's something i love about it really
because the ants are sort of a study in
what happens when you take away the
concepts of human stigma
expectation and judgment there are a few
rules involved in ant culture
and a few expectations but the fact that
the ant who followed leia all around
dismissed him immediately once he was
dead didn't feel like a hugely bad thing
to me they were
allies they weren't together out of an
emotional connection and it never seemed
that way if anything she was with him
because he provided safety and comfort
and while we as humans tend to associate
that with emotional connection there's
no reason to believe that that's the
case for anyone or anything else
speaking of emotional connections i
simply do not remember the order of
operations i suppose kite would have
been edible immediately but why was he
hiding in the empty cavern of a dead ant
as a small child a baby and of course
jing crawls out of the woodwork to run
the hunters association and i really
feel like he's too much of a doofus
based on what we've seen but it also
very much tracks with the sense of
ambition involved in the freak family
let's check out episode 137
and see if anything gets any better 137
and it's a whole new group of people
members of the zodiac great i'm not
gonna remember this
though the animals are cute as heck and
i love the idea that jing is a pig and i
like
how these animals work they look cute
but i'll never see that again and i will
never remember
that the idea that jing is one of the
zodiacs is an odd one especially given
last episode i would have assumed he was
coming to take over and
and i did assume he was coming to take
over i said it like less than a minute
ago i'm fairly sure you know
you only see people like bisoft doing
the admin on shows like this and i think
it's been seriously overlooked but then
again
there's beans beans i like beans
i love that name i think it's a
fantastic name i think
everyone should have a friend called
beans looking at the new opening credits
also we have
a miss trunchbull and we get back to
leorio who has maybe learned to do a
thing but not kurapika because
grubbica's had his arc like why would he
come back that seems silly the episode
is remarkably light-hearted and
obviously is designed to set up the new
ark and it will
be an interesting arc we have hiskey
back we have a whole load of hunters and
we have a situation in which we get to
see the freaky family spending time
being freaky and strange
it seems as though jing feels the same
way about natero as
gon does mostly in fact more there's a
sense that jing is as lacking in subtext
as gone but at the same time seems to
have a whole lot more of it i'm not too
sure what to make of him if i'm honest
rat though rat is a concern largely
because he's annoyingly obvious
i actually do like rat which is a
strange thing for me to say
at the beginning of the arc but a
stranger thing for me to say in the tone
that i said it and i said it like that
because
i rarely make such a snap decision about
characters and i quite
like what rat seems designed to do
i quite like what rat seems designed to
do yeah i said it that said
he is a concern largely because he's
annoyingly obvious
i don't know if i like this new band of
people but then i struggle with the
transition from each arc to the next
because i get attached to the story as
it was then don't want to move on i
don't know i
don't understand how this pacing works
but i feel jarred
as i do watch these one by one the way
it would have been seen originally i do
wonder sometimes whether i should take a
break at the end of one arc to
emotionally disconnect from the last
group of hair-brained warriors to empty
the cache of information
ready for a new one i can only keep so
many names in my head at one time and i
feel like i shouldn't be expected to
remember 11 new names but this is me
rehashing my issue with tagashi's
writing when it comes to the opening of
arcs and it's been a while
but like a shakespeare play start slow
bring your people into it
please please i beg and i can only
assume it's the last arc that exists
because we're getting very close to the
end of what i'm seeing is available it's
quite difficult to talk about this
episode because it's all set up rather
than anything else and as much as i'm
somewhat interested in the storyline
being presented and the fact that it's a
return to the hunter exam concept
there's a feeling of inadequacy that
comes from having been so far away from
the concept of the hunter exam
and then just bowing here we are we've
returned to it but then that's the point
of the sequence i guess
to see after all that emotion after all
the heartbreak and loss and realizing
that humans are the real monsters
nothing effectively changes the world as
i said keeps turning and so we returned
to the points we were at before
because we simply don't have a choice to
do anything else
we continue on our monstrous path with
people like hisoka
and illumi and we note that there's
another zoldic apparently
more zolder yay hisoka's desire to fight
people continues
and did it ever stop and in fact you
know what if he wanted to find the
ultimate person to fight he should have
tried getting off his butt and helping
out with the ants he missed out on
fighting an ant king
i don't get it and he's here looking for
jing when it would make so much more
sense
i just from power perspective i don't
understand why i should care about this
situation now and and that's part of it
why now why this arc now why is this
happening here why is this happening now
i'm not seeing that what is it about
this that's important i understand that
gone finally meeting his dad
is hugely important to the narrative of
the overall story the overarching story
gone
was searching for his dad that was the
point but beyond that
especially since gone wasn't the focus
of the last arc like it's
hard to connect i feel less connected to
all of this than i want to
that said maybe laughing at these newer
almost by necessity weaker characters
will be an enjoyable situation and so i
shall do my best not to judge and i will
only say
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
lack of surety about the next arc and
the enjoyment of the end of the last
click here here and here do all the good
things keep warm or cool depending on
your climate and i'll see you next time